اسم الفنان الاردني الراحل اشرف طلفاح ما
زال في قوائم بحث الاردنيين والمصريين
والعرب ولسه مستمرين بمتابعه تطورات وفاه
والمؤسفه اللي وقعت من يومين خلال وجوده
في مصر والليله الان منتدى تحقيقات فيها
بشكل نهائي فاللي صار انه فجاه نزل خبر
وفاه الفنان في مصر بعد اعتداء من مسؤولين
لقصر الناس كمان بيتداولوا صور من تقرير
طبي قالوا انه للراحل لكن هاي الاخبار
سرعان فتى سلطات المصريه والاردنيه واللي
نشرت بيانات رسميه وضحت فيها تفاصيل
النيابه العامه المصريه اللي بتحقق في
الحادث كشفت انه عثر عليه مغمى عليه في
البيت ونقل للمستشفى وكان ما يزال على قيد
الحياه والشرطه ما وجدت اي اثر عنف في
البيت من بره او جوه لكن جسمه كان في اثار
اصابات متفرقه وجروح وحروق والكشف الطفل
بين اصابته بنزيف في المخ وتجمع الدموي
وارتشاح في الرئه بالعام المصريه قالت
البيان انه للان لم تقف على دلائل لاي شبه
جنائيه وانتدبت الطب الشرعي لاجراء الصفه
تشريحيه وبيان سبب كيفيه الاصابه لا بيان
مدى وجود ما يشير لوجود شبهه جنائيه في
وفاته بالنسبه للخارجيه الاردنيه هي كمان
بدورها اصدرت بيان اكدت في متابعتها لا
تطورات تحقيقات مع الجانب المصري وانه
تحقيقات الاوليه اثبتت انه ما في شبه
جنائيه وانه نتائج تحقيقات راح تعلن فور
الانتهاء منها والسفاره متابعتها بالتنسيق
مع شقيق الراحل وعائلته
[موسيقى]